despite the dozens of federal agencies
that are shut down this morning many
more will remain operational throughout
the standoff the US Postal Service will
continue regular mail delivery Social
Security checks will be sent out and
Medicare and Medicaid coverage will
continue TSA agents will stay on the job
providing security at airports but will
not get paid special counsel Robert
Muller's Russian investigation will
continue and the Smithsonian Museum and
National Zoo in Washington DC will
remain open through at least January
first here to discuss some of this
week's major developments is the heel
cup for national political reporter for
Bloomberg News so he'll good morning to
you so we've heard the blame game
mentioned several times we just said it
at this point where things stand right
now what is the political fallout from
this partial shutdown well we are firmly
in blame game territory the politics of
shutdowns always come down to who is to
blame and Democrats are saying this is
the Trump shutdown they are saying this
is a temper tantrum tantrum that the
president has thrown he'll take the
blame for that that's right he is on
tape saying he'll take the blame I own
this he says he'll be proud to shut down
the government over the issue of border
security in the wall and the president's
allies are saying if only Democrats
could have accepted this wall and given
him some money for it he campaigned on
it we could have avoided the shutdown
chief campaign promise so if this
do-or-die for president Trump it
absolutely is this is the issue on which
he has built his political identity this
was his answer to voters as the source
of their grievances you know he said
immigration uncontrolled migration
existing laws are the reason their jobs
are going away he's blamed that for
crime he said that's even the cause of
the opioid epidemic now these are very
simplistic answers to complex problems
but they are answers and polls show that
his voters Republican voters
overwhelmingly accept that and they are
you know drawn to this issue they
support the wall in large numbers but
the problem is the American public at
large opposes it so he's caught in this
box yes I mean his position actually
changed because he got so much flak from
the right when he seemed to be backing
away
that's correct and senator bob Corker
the retiring Tennessee Republican called
that juvenile referring to the president
that reversal he says this is a tyranny
of talk radio in other words some voices
on the right are basically controlling
actions of the White House in his words
one of the other big stories this week's
Secretary of Defense James Madison
ounces his resignation putting a letter
out there that so many people were
reading into this week one of the big
things we heard is with Matt asleeping
it will be the last adult in the room
now gone what is the fallout from this
right well Maddox was seen as a big
believer of the post-world War two order
the institutions that have prevented
another bloody catastrophe of that sort
from happening his letter was an
astonishing denunciation in many ways of
the president's worldview he talked
about the importance of treating allies
with respect and being clear-eyed about
Millian actor seemed to be a reference a
lot of people took to the president's
you know very strong criticism at times
of allies like France and Germany and
his cozy relationship with authoritarian
leaders in Russia and North Korea and
interesting too he omitted that
salutation a very respectfully at the
end of that letter there was no such you
know reference to that that is normally
in a resignation letter unusual for a
Secretary of Defense to go out like this
being critical of a sitting presidents
policy the the the resignation was of
course sparked by the pullout of troops
from Syria the president said Isis in
Syria has been defeated but he's getting
pushback on that from both Democrats and
Republicans he is getting a lot of
pushback people say it's a hasty
withdrawal that didn't go through the
interagency process that even seemed to
shock some of his own you know some
people in his administration that are
overseeing these military operations the
bipartisan criticism was also that Isis
has not been defeated but the president
is sticking to his guns he is not moving
on this you know he has talked about how
he doesn't want the United States to be
the policeman of the world you know he
said we're spending too much money in
countries around the Middle East without
getting much for it and frankly this
stuff plays well politically across the
spectrum quickly any glimmer of hope
reversing his decision you know in terms
of you see this bipartisanship out there
you know with the criminal justice
reform oh well this was a modest series
of steps that was seen as kind of a long
overdue correction to some of the
excesses you know of the tough-on-crime
era of the 80s and 90s it passed with an
overwhelming vote 358 members of the
House 87 senators everyone from
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders on
the Left Rand Paul and Michael Lee on
the right
everyone from the ACLU to the Koch
brothers it's very rare but this is a
modest step and I would not expect it to
be replicated on too many issues Wow
Hill Kapoor yeah we thank you very much
thank you